[تصفيق]
تعود الانسان منذ القرن الماضي على
الاستهلاك الكبير للمواد البلاستيكيه
فصارت جزءا لا يتجزا من حياته حيث ان
الحياه صارت سريعه وفي تطور مستمر وزاد
الاستهلاك من المواد البلاستيكيه حيث انه
من عام
1995 الى
2018 وصل الاستهلاك الى تقريبا الى
360 مليون طن وهذه النسبه في تزايد مستمر
هذا الموضوع طبيعي ومتوقع ولكن الامر
الغير طبيعي هو وصول الجزيئات البلاستيكيه
الى دمائنا واجسادنا
حيث ان الدراسات الحاليه تقول ان تقريبا
80% من الاشخاص يحتوي دمهم على
البلاستيك يعني تقريب يعني قد يكون دمك
ودمي ودم اطفالنا ودم اجيالنا القادمه قد
يحتوي على البلاستيك وهذا البلاستيك من
شانه ان يسبب التهابات وخلل في الجهاز
المناعي وايضا بعض انواع السرطانات تخيلوا
معي سنه 2050 مع تقدم التطور ومن المتوقع
ان يكون اعداد البلاستيك في البحار اكثر
من عدد الاسماك كم بتكون النسبه في دمائنا
اذا ما كان في حل لهذه المشكله وهل ستكون
دمائنا عباره عن بلاستيك في احدى المرات
كان معي لقاء اذاعي وبعد هذا اللقاء كثرت
التعليقات من ضمن هذه التعليقات تقول اذا
كان سميه تعرف 250 كم عدد البلاستيك في
البحار معناته سميه تعرف رواتبنا 250
وتعليقات اخرى اللي يقول في قبري 2050
خلاص خمسه اشياء يعني بعيدا عن ذلك كله
صحيح تعليقات ونحنا نعلق لكن هذا هذه
احصائيات من هيئه الامم المتحده وتقول ان
البلاستيك في تزايد
مستمر خطوره البلاستيك نفسه كبيره ولكن
الاخطر هو تحول هذا البلاستيك الى جزيئات
بسيطه تسمى المايكرو بلاستيك ما هو
المايكرو بلاستيك هو جزيئات بلاستيكيه
دقيقه يعني بسبب تفتت هذا البلاستيك
الكبير بفعل الاشعاع والحراره وايضا
الاحتكاك يحول الى جزيئات بسيطه جدا من 5
مليمتر فما تحت يعني بعضه نراه بالعين
المجرده وبعضه لا يمكن ان نراه بالعين
المجرده هذا البلاستيك الدقيق والمايكرو
بلاستيك يتخلل الى اجسامنا بسهوله يعني
اثبتت الدراسات وجود هذا البلاستيك في
الهواء وفي الغبار وفي الماء وايضا في
مياه الشرب وكذلك ينتقل الينا عن طريق
السلسله الغذائيه عن طريق الاسماك احدى
الدراسات في
2019 100 نوع تم جلب 100 نوع من الاسماك
من اربع قارات وتم دراسه الجزيئات
والاعضاء فيها اثبتت ان 80% من هذه
الاسماك يحتوي اعضاءها على
البلاستيك يعني المخيف من الامر ان في
المستقبل بعض الكائنات الحيه اللي موجوده
في بيئتنا واللي هي ثرواتنا وكنوزه قد
تنقرض وقد
تختفي يعني مشكله البلاستيك نقدر نسميها
غزو
بلاستيكي بعد هذا العب البلاستيكي الكبير
قررت اني اكرس جهودي البحثيه وابحث عن حل
يخلصنا من هذه المشكله وهذا الغزو
البلاستيكي بطريقه صديقه
للبيئه فقررت اني انزل لساحه المعركه واني
اكون الهجوم ضد هذا الغزو
البلاستيكي كررت الجهود عب خلال سنوات
وخلال هذه السنوات اكتشفت ابتكار عن طريقه
نستطيع ان نتخلص من الجزيئات البلاستيكيه
الدقيقه بصوره سريعه تع وكم سنه البلاستيك
يحتاج ل عشان يتحلل عند كم فكره يحتاج ل
500 عام حتى
يتفكك يعني تخيلوا الاجيال القادمه كيف
يكون وضعها مع الاستمرار الاستهلاك لمواد
البلاستيكيه لا ننكر اهميه المواد
البلاستيكيه وان المصانع تتنافس في صنع
المواد البلاستيكيه والمستشفيات ايضا بها
مواد بلاستيكيه ولكن لابد ان نفكر في
الاجيال القادمه ايكوس فير المنتج الذي
اكتشفته يستطيع ان يتخلص من الجزيئات
البلاستيكيه الدقيقه بطريقه صديقه للبيئه
يخلصنا من هذا القاتل
الخفي يحول هذا البلاستيك من مركبات معقده
الى مركبات بسيطه وايضا هذا المنتج هذ
اوهه عباره عن ميكروبات بالاضافه الى
طريقه النانو تكنولوجي دمج الطريقتين
اثبتت ان هذه الطريقه تعتبر سريعه جدا
وايضا صديقه
للبيئه نتمنى ان يكون هذا المنتج على ارض
الواقع لان دائما الدراسات في هذا المجال
وبمجال خاصه التحلل البيولوجي عباره عن
اوراق علميه ولكن ما فائده هذه الاوراق
العلميه اذا ما كان لها تطبيق على ارض
الواقع اذا ما كانت تنقذنا وتنقذ اجيالنا
القادمه خطوات بسيطه جدا منكم ومني نستطيع
ان نحل هذه المشكله وهذا الغزو البلاستيكي
اعطيكم بعض الامثله من واقع حياتنا عشان
نكون مكملين لبعض ونكون نحن الفرق في
التغيير ونقلل العبئ للاجيال القادمه
اعطيكم امثله من بيئتنا من واقع حياتنا
اكياس التسوق اللي نحن ناخذها دائما من
المحلات ليش ما نحن نستخدم اكياس معنا في
البيت وتكون هذه الاكياس نستخدمها اكثر من
مره بدل من احنا نجلب هذه الاكياس من
الاسواق بالاضافه الى
ذلك قنينات الماء قنينات الماء نحن نستخدم
قنينات الماء اللي هي يعني هذه القنينات
اللي مصنوعه من بولي اثلين تفليت اللي هي
موجوده في المحلات قنينات الماء العاديه
تعرفوا الدراسه اللي قلت لكم ان 80% من
الاشخاص يحتوي دمهم على البلاستيك كان 50%
من هذه النسبه عباره عن بوليثين تتليت
واللي هو اكثر استهلاك نحنا نستهلكه في
ايامنا
العاديه لو نحن نستخدم قنينه ماء وايضا
لشرب الشاي والقهوه اللي هي ممكن نعيد
استخدامها مره اخرى بدل من نحنا نستخدم
البلاستيكيه والتي ترمى وتهدر وايضا
تتراكم في البيئه كذلك سفره الطعام في
المنزل انا انا متاكده واراهن ان جميعنا
او اغلبنا نستخدم السفرات اللي هي مستخدمه
لمره واحده صحيح وهذه بعد ذلك ايضا تكون
يعني في القمامه وايضا تتراكم وهذا يعتبر
عب بلاستيكي لنا ولاجي لنا القادمه هناك
طرق بسيطه جدا بما ان نحن جزء من هذه
المشكله الكبيره وهذا الغزو البلاستيكي
نستطيع ان نكون الحل لننقذ ونؤمن مستقبل
مستدام ولا جيالنا
[تصفيق]
القادمه